jackass is at its best when a simple
task is carried out on the most
outrageous Way Knoxville and his band of
Knuckleheads can imagine such is the
case in Lamborghini tooth pull from
Jackass 3D former professional
snowboarder danger Aaron needs a tooth
pulled so naturally The Chosen method of
extraction is a length of extra strong
fishing line with the tooth on one end
and bambergera's Lamborghini on the
other Aaron sits in a dentist chair in
the middle of a racetrack while majera
floors her sports car in the opposite
direction it's difficult to tell what
the most horrifying element is in this
stunts the distinct to pop a sound that
accompanies a tooth being pulled from
Aaron's mouth his screams of Agony and
inability to regain composure afterwards
or the fact that the stuns didn't just
pull its tooth but as he told the
Willamette Week broke his face quote all
the way up to almost his eye